[موسيقى]
من دون نوفمبر الماضي تكثف القوات الروسيه
ضربتها بالصواريخ والمسيرات على البنيه
التحتيه الاوكرانيه لذلك تسعه كياب لتشكيل
ما تسميه درعا دفاعيا جويه تطلب القياده
الاوكرانيه من حلفائها الغربيين منظومات
للدفاع الجوي وهي تنتظر وصول المنظومه
الامريكيه باتريت لكن الامر لم يتوقف على
الطلب من الامريكيين فقط قدمت فرنسا
منظومه خرسال النرويج قدمت منظومه
شمستي من المانيا بالاضافه الى ابسيد 2000
من ايطاليا ما يخلق دفاعا ونوعا كما تريد
كيف لكن الامر ينعطف للتعقيل اكثر من وجهه
نظر عسكريا ليس من السهل امتلاكم مجموعه
متنوعه من الامر في كل من هذه الانظمه
نطقها الخاص الى جانب احتياجات التدريب
ومشاكل الامداد واداره مخزون الصواريخ